this is the way it translated in my mind
if i'm powerful enough
to create in my body all of these rare
diseases
what would happen if i had that took
that same power and created this life of
my dreams
and it felt i i saw it as power
rather than weakness
and so from a complete negativity victim
person that i was
that was really different for me to have
that thought but i believe
that little mind change that little
switch
started the healing in my body
and within three months
i was off of all meds
with the help of my physicians all of
them if you deal with your trauma but
you're still treating your body like
trash and eating junk and whatever else
like that's not going to be good either
really right versus oh i'm like doing
all the right health things but you're
not dealing with stuff your body's not
going to integrate those healthy things
well either like it's both it's
basically both absolutely it's holistic
you have the power already within you
if you'll just harness it
[Music]
two people are in a field of clovers
both of them are looking for four-league
clovers one of them believes they will
find four-leaf clovers and the other one
does not
which one is going to find four-leaf
clovers
kent and heather mckean share
information in this podcast conversation
on how to heal from trauma and optimize
your life i want to warn you this is a
different way of looking at issues like
mental health than you may be used to
it's such a radically different
perspective that if you've struggled
with mental health issues or long-term
physical health issues this might stir
some things up for you
it might make you angry or even want to
turn off this episode so i want to give
a warning for anyone who's not in the
heart space to receive this type of
information and i'm so sorry for what
you're struggling through and it's not
your fault if i heard this information
years before i was ready i might have
felt triggered too i might have
internalized their message and made it
personal but i came across this
information at a time when my heart was
extremely open and i've personally
experienced mind change in a way that
has transformed my life in more ways
than one
what's incredible is that two people can
have the same experience and view that
experience in completely different ways
that's the power of the mind there's a
reason scientific studies includes a
placebo group partly to take into
account the participants perception also
known as the placebo effect it's because
the mind can be very influential in the
outcome
i'm generally a very positive person but
there have been situations where i found
myself spiraling mentally over something
that happened in my life and letting
that thing that happened take over my
life to where i missed out on being
present i turned into someone i didn't
want to be angry hyper emotional easily
pissed off and distracted all because of
my mind no one could help me out of it
until i was ready to be helped until i
was ready to help myself
until i became a victor not a victim and
healed from my trauma if you want to
heal from your past ranging from small
experiences that stuck with you all the
way to abuse and neglect and loss you
have to face your heartache and trauma
head-on to change your mind
shoving your pain down deep inside of
you pretending it's not there neglecting
your inner child who wants to heal does
not heal you your subconscious is so
powerful you can do all the positive
affirmations you want but if you don't
address your subconscious you might go
to a place where you don't even
recognize yourself anymore and act and
think in ways that your true highest
self wouldn't
every one of you is worthy of healing
and living a life full of joy and
confidence and living the life you
desire
love is the strongest medicine show
yourself love which in turn ripples out
to others because you are already enough
please keep in mind i'm aware of how
controversial these perspectives and
following stories are we are not unaware
of the typical view of mental and
physical health this is a radically
different way of understanding the mind
and how it works in the body your health
is all-encompassing and the mind and
body are inseparable
and it's crucial that you understand
going into this that this is not your
fault
rather this message is meant to empower
you
if after listening to this episode you
are pumped and your heart is open to
this concept check out heather and kent
mckean's mind change course which will
give you the tools to tap into your
subconscious and change your mind which
will then change your life i will link
in the description box below for you
guys and i also got a discount for you
as well use my code ln50 for 50 off the
course now let's get into this episode i
hope you enjoy it
all right thank you guys so much for
being here when i was like envisioning
the podcast and figuring out my first
like definitely 15 10 20 episodes you
guys were definitely on my list i really
want to talk about this and it's such an
important topic so thank you so much for
being here oh thanks for having us our
pleasure for people who don't know
when we bought our first house in paella
we were getting settled in and just a
few weeks later
the mckeans bought a house right next
door and that is where our friendship
story begins and we've had so many
amazing experiences together including
mind change stuff which we'll get into
yeah
so for those who are like what the heck
is mind change can you just explain like
before we get into your guys stories
like what is mind change
it's a great question
um i would say if i had to give my
little elevator speech which again we're
not haven't nailed down it's basically
a way to reprogram our minds
using neuroplasticity so it's we're able
to get in and reprogram and retrain and
rewire
our brains which then affects our body
and i mean that's the basis of it it's
got a lot of different
we'll get into it yeah we'll get into it
but that i would say that's the basic
way of describing it okay cool anything
you want to add to that ken yeah i mean
it's a
neuroscience-based therapy that really
uh
reprograms reconstructs the neural
pathways in our brain so that we no
longer i mean we're
95 to 99 of our behaviors
are subconscious and so if you reprogram
your subconscious then not only do you
feel different but you act different
without even thinking about it and so
yeah it's it's a really incredible tool
that uh
i'm proud of my wife for
for creating
i feel like that's super important to
consider the subconscious most of us
don't even think about the subconscious
because obviously it's subconscious but
we don't give any kind of weight to like
the power behind any changing even the
subconscious right i feel like so much
we're kind of thinking you can't even
change your mind that's kind of the
thing like it's kind of considered
what's the word oh gosh you really think
law of attraction all that type of thing
yeah but it's so much more important
than that well science even said up
until 20 years ago that by the time
we're
20 years old 30 years old generously
we're hardwired there's no change after
that science used to say that but our
brains were static wow i'm not
changeable i didn't know that so
that's where in the last 20 years with
brain imaging technology they've been
able to see things light up i mean
they're getting in there like whoa this
is not what we thought it was
and that's the beauty of and if i could
just start it out by saying the beauty
of what we've created and what we do
is that it's
coming from
the personal experience which i'll share
but also it's not a reductionist kind of
focus we've learned so much from
reductionist thinking in one sense
focusing on the brain people have spent
their entire lives focusing on the brain
or people who've spent their entire
lives focusing on the body but they have
not been able to yet connect the two and
and really if that would be a whole line
of
new learning for them new focus so
people like us come along and we're able
to take all this beautiful wonderful
information and apply it to us as a
whole being which is what we are and we
can't really do anything especially
healing outside of the wholeness that we
are so that's where we can take the new
neuroscience and apply it to what we
already know
from physiology
psychology but also spirituality if we
can step back and go what's the good
what have they all learned and put it
all together
that's mind change and would you say
that like we have more control
to like the outcome of our lives than we
realize is that a good way to explain it
as well if we choose and that's the
power that we have we either and we may
talk about this but we either give our
power away constantly or we allow the
power to be from within and we do
everything everything comes from within
so we're either giving it away here you
go here you go or we actually are living
from within and that's that's a huge
part of being authentic which
i'll talk about my in authenticity and
authenticity
yeah so how about you guys share then
like what are your mind change stories
where did you come from yeah that's
really
this all started with you
okay so i used to kind of have this
trauma story right that uh i had come
from a difficult background there was
physical abuse
neglect my parents you know
drugs and alcohol and all of that stuff
so that was kind of my story
and i would
speak about it
and
uh
use that as a platform to you know
encourage people because look at how
strong i am how well-adjusted i am that
i didn't end up an addict or you know
all these different things
so i thought because i could speak about
it without you know breaking down or
feeling a lot about it that i was good
even with that kind of a history and
i would say that's a preferable way at
least for me it was preferable to do
that than to go down the you know
addiction route or
various different things
but
trauma doesn't just go away it has to be
processed out of the body and if it's
not it gets stored and it comes out
somehow
so for me the way that it came out was
physical illness
so in
2012 yeah i start at the end of the
story i ended up i'm at home on an iv
drip liver and kidney failure
really near death we were having
conversations about like making plans
for what was going to happen if he was
going to be a single dad and i mean we
were having to have those real
conversations
and i had gotten to that point by being
diagnosed with disease after disease
after disease i mean it's
silly to think about
and and even then even in the midst of
it i was like how can one person have so
many
serious incurable rare diseases what did
you have what were you like diagnosed
with so it kind of started i was i had
some
i wouldn't say i was a healthy child
um but i also didn't feel like i was
sickly so only when i look back that i'm
like oh the recurrent tonsillitis or
i had a lot of different gut issues and
you know different stuff like that
but
when i got pregnant or well i had
infertility endometriosis i bled nine
months threw up every morning for about
nine months
that led to an endometriosis diagnosis
two surgeries
that led to a celiac disease diagnosis
then chronic fatigue syndrome then
fibromyalgia ibs everything else and
then all the stuff around the gut health
stuff so yeah ibs all of that then it
became thyroid issues
so then it was hyperthyroid hypothyroid
then it was graves disease and
hashimoto's which you can't have
you can't have both they're opposite of
one another but i got both diagnosis i
got a goiter it was like a whole thing
wow then i'd say probably the biggest
diagnosis that was like my rabbit hole
was lyme disease
and when i got diagnosed with lyme
disease it just went into this spiral
then i then i was diagnosed with pots
which is a heart condition really and
i'm terrible it's supposed to be
incurable
and
then i it was in an infectious disease
doctor and i had some rare form of
malaria that you can only get in africa
but i've never been to africa
and all this stuff was showing up in
blood tests and was like there
one of the other really big things is i
had a lot of problems with my neck and
back
and so i'd seen neurologists i'd had
surgeries um they were i was told i had
the spine this was in my in my 20s the
spine of a 70 year old
and that i would probably if i kept
living the life that i was living end up
paralyzed because everything was bone on
bone and my spine they called it
degenerative disc disease so he was like
your discs are just crumbling wow so
you're not gonna like you
and i do have two discs fused before i
started this whole journey and he said
i'd end up with a completely fused at
least
cervical spine and possibly possibly you
know moving down because i had a lot of
stuff with my leg back like you said
that was inevitable inevitable and that
well even after the surgery that you the
doctor said this is because of the fuse
of these two you're only going to be
able to move this much which was true
for
what four years until this work and so
obviously yeah i couldn't turn my head
in your head you can do whatever i could
i would turn like this
i can't turn like i couldn't turn i
thought i couldn't turn and i thought
that it was all you know this physical
stuff
so after that lyme disease diagnosis oh
my heavens that started then i
about six months into that
i found myself on 180
medications a day
no i know i have pictures no one would
believe it i have lists and stuff but
this tells you why i went into liver and
kidney failure like nobody can do that
shots it was shots pills tinctures
i was on four shots a day for rheumatoid
arthritis i got diagnosed with this
arthritis i was on two shots for that
which were immunosuppressive
i was taking all of these heavy-duty
medicines that were like
side effects hearing loss
eyesight loss you know heart issues
like all of this stuff death
death it was like you could just die you
know
so it didn't say that but it was like
you know all these different things that
could happen
so
that's where i feel like my body just
started shutting down physically
and it wasn't until i'd had a couple of
friends and people in my life that said
do you think your past has anything to
do with this
and i was like no i have no issues with
my past like i can talk about it i don't
i don't crying in my wheaties because of
my past this was my idea about it
of like i haven't it doesn't bother me
so you really had this identity of like
i'm not affected by my past and i don't
i don't need sympathy i don't need
empathy i don't need to
no i'm over
even worse it sound it was sounded good
then
but even worse i know now is it made me
stronger it made me who i am
my past is as if
it took being physically sexually abused
for me to be this strong woman
like i was so
i didn't even realize it how messed up i
was in my head about that i do sometimes
hear that and i think that that does add
value sometimes though when people are
like that my past made me who i am today
i am stronger for because of it like
sometimes that that story does make
sense to me but does that not make sense
to you it used to and i get it
but it's like it's but if we if we go
deeper if we scratch the surface of that
i'll add to that
our past does make us who we are today
but it's how we represent our past and
so if we represent our past from the
trauma and all the issues and whatever
and that's our representation of our
past making us who we are today then the
only thing we're going to be today and
tomorrow is something stemming from
trauma
but if we use our past and we can still
be you know from our past but we're
going forward from a different
perspective from a different place from
a healed place right then you go today
and tomorrow from a healed place from
your past so there's a different way of
looking at it right so is that kind of
like like tony robbins you know him he
kind of talks about that and it's his
story is really beautiful and amazing do
you feel like that's a the way of like
the latter of what you said like coming
from a healed
version does that make sense yeah i mean
that's that's huge right because you can
look at a trauma and say well because of
that bad thing i'm gonna be a different
way or because of this and i've made
peace with it i'm healed from it and
that's not who i am anymore but i've
learned this and you're kind of coming
from a higher perspective right um so i
think that's right whereas maybe you
were going like i had this and i don't
even need to deal with it like i've
completely it's not even something that
you have to touch there's a difference
between i'll say there's a difference
between
reaction and response so a lot of people
from their trauma react and live a
certain way
versus if you're dealing with it and
you're healed from it you can respond in
a different way that's so interesting
it's it gets i mean especially in our
culture right now
i i'm mindful of you know we've got a
lot of stuff about victim shaming we do
this though we swing the pendulum we go
from don't talk about your stuff don't
be a baby suck it up and move on
to
this other side which is this kind of
like
well this is you know i wouldn't be who
i am today without all this stuff that
happened it's the only way i can relate
to people like my story makes me have
value
that's what i take issue with okay i
would argue you were already valuable it
didn't take someone sexually molesting
you
for you to be valuable yes i see what
you're saying in the way you're
explaining it for sure yeah but it
because it and i know that it we can
make sense of it in our languaging and
in our conscious mind but the problem is
the subconscious mind doesn't make sense
of it that way it links so for me that
was keeping me sick and i didn't realize
it
and i also i had a lot of infertility
issues couldn't get pregnant
and of course then you blame the
endometriosis or whatever
and it all makes sense but what i know
now
is from an evolutionary perspective
we are carrying generational trauma down
and it has not been addressed
for so many generations
and it isn't doing well for us as a
species to not have dealt with this
stuff because it's exponentially
building upon itself yes so epigenetics
is the study that tells us that trauma
can be passed down in our genes
and the holocaust they've done a lot of
study on holocaust survivors second
generation holocaust survivors
showing up in their dna stuff like
malnutrition
a lot of ptsd issues mental health
issues these are not the people
that went through the holocaust these
are their children and their
grandchildren
so i i say all that to say there's this
idea that you know that that if our
trauma makes us and everything we need
to be dealing with this stuff and we
haven't been given the tools i think to
do so right and is some of that maybe
it's a little bit genetics and maybe
it's also when the parents aren't
dealing with their trauma they're
reacting in the way that they end up
parenting and of course exuding and
showing their life as an example
and
it impacts the children as well 100 yeah
so that whole nature versus nurture
debate is still i mean it's both it's
both yeah it's always going to be both
and in a moment you'll hear like a
little bit about her childhood you'll
hear my childhood and then you'll you'll
see that oh it actually doesn't matter
yes so i bring that up to say i really
do believe now that my body was saying
like
don't bring children
into this world
when you've got all this stuff you're
gonna pass down i didn't have the tools
to deal with it
and i was carrying a lot of stuff
stuff i wasn't really remembering even
and not completely in touch with so i
think my body protecting me
was like do you really want to do this i
didn't have a great relationship with my
mother with my family
so i did all this infertility stuff i
was on a lot of shots and did a lot of
stuff finally got pregnant but it was
when i got pregnant and then had my
children that my body was just like no
and that started that cascade of all
these illnesses and diseases
and i really believe it was this
you know i didn't know it at the time
this was a subconscious thing i didn't
think i could raise kids healthy i
didn't have any healthy examples
i didn't think i could do it and i
didn't want
to pass down what i did have so
emotionally healthy um yeah or
physically too like there were so many
things that i just realized and i
thought i had a narrative i was broken
you know of course with my past i'm
gonna end up like this
and you know all these different things
so that metaphorically you felt broken
and then physically she was i mean i
remember when our kids were little
before all of this
um you know it was like no be careful
with mom don't jump on don't do that you
know it was a constant
be careful because mom is frail okay and
she does legitimately but it wasn't just
physical stuff it was it was a physical
fragility that was manifesting from an
emotional fragility but you could not
have told me i was emotionally fragile
no i'd have sucked you probably
so no i was not emotionally fragile i
was emotionally strong
but what that really meant was i felt
all of two emotions anger and fine
that was me being emotionally strong so
if you got in my way i would get really
angry and i could protect myself that
way
and i could do okay and those were my
range of emotions and i think that
motherhood parenthood calls us into that
deeper place like i've got to be able to
feel a range of emotions if i'm going to
have a child
or they're going to learn how to not
emote and feel like that's not okay
right and i would never have known that
at the time
so that's where i think my body just
spiraled down and then i'm home
on an iv drip and a doctor comes to my
house
and because they were coming to see me
at my house at that point because i
couldn't really get out i mean i was
going in for iv infusions twice a week
but at this point i was so sick i could
barely leave my house
so
he says to me
have you heard of tapping
and i said no i haven't heard of tapping
and but i'm willing to try anything
which he knows i mean i've tried so many
things so he knows that i'm open to
anything so he said well i don't know a
lot about it but i've heard that some
people have success with it i was like
okay i will look this up so i just
google tapping and it takes me to the
tapping solution which is the ortner's
and
so i start to look into this okay what
is this what is this stuff and what i
know now is that it's what they do is
eft
um it's been around for many years but
it's emotional freedom technique and so
their theory is that trauma
or
just things that happen to us get stored
in our body as energy blocks
and so it's like our meridians or our
chakras get blocked by these traumatic
experiences
and to open them up you need to tap
and that's where the tapping solution
and so it's like you tap on all these
different meridian points right and you
speak as you're tapping like let's say
i've got pain you this pain this pain
this pain this pain this pain this pain
and you do this all this whole series
down your body
and i was like
okay
i mean okay i guess i could i could see
that
and then it's like so this is what you
do like for every trauma or for every
pain or everything that's going and i
was like oh
and then i'm gonna die sick because
that's gonna take me forever right
so um so then i started looking more
into that
and looking for alter you know alternate
faster types of things you know or
anybody who knows because there's
something about that that i was like
okay
someone's telling me that my trauma
might have something to do with this and
that is one angle i had not tried yet
and so my friends voices are kind of
coming up into my mind and i was like
all right let's let's look at this then
so
that really opened this up and started
this journey for me
and i went to a
training
for this
for this stuff it was like an eft based
training
and thought well let me learn and let me
see if i can get well
and i was i had literally a suitcase i
wasn't supposed to go anywhere and here
i'm hopping on a you know a flight to go
do this
we need to get her a bigger suitcase so
she could take all her meds with her yes
like we had spent so much money i think
we figured it out like out of pocket
through this whole thing yeah somewhere
around i don't know a hundred thousand
dollars for everything that i had done
so we're like
i'm on disability i can't even work
he's not making much money it was this
whole thing and i thought i've got to do
something one more thing
and
went to this training and there was a
lot involved in it but one of the things
that was said was
that
we're doing this basically i'm doing it
to myself
wow how did that feel right okay so let
me tell you
normal heather
would have been like them's fighting
words like i'm so sick i can't be there
for my kids you're saying i did this
i could have heard it that way but i
didn't and i don't think that was
actually the way it was meant
i think what i heard for like probably
the first time in my life was
this is the way it translated in my mind
if i'm powerful enough
to create in my body
all of these rare diseases
what would happen if i had that took
that same power and created this life of
my dreams
and it felt i i saw it as power
rather than weakness
and so from a complete negativity victim
person that i was
that was really different for me to have
that thought but i believe
that little mind change that little
switch
started the healing in my body
and within three months
i was off of all meds
with the help of my physicians all of
them they helped me titrate off i went
back and i was like i'm
well i just need my body to catch up
and these very mainstream doctors were
supporting me
and were like okay
let's do this so um i remember
one of the first major appointments i
had was with my cardiologist so i would
have and i'd have a big one every year
to go in and i'd have to sit and i'd
have to do this bike and do all this
stuff and do an ekg and all of these
things this was for the pots condition
which i medicated for and everything so
i literally two weeks after i got back
had my two or my one year appointment
with this cardiologist
and i walk in and i have to go through
all this stuff with the nurses first
they hook me up to an ekg and he's going
through my file so i'm hooked up to the
ekg akg but i'm like i'm healed right in
my mind i'm like i'm good i'm better
he starts going through my history about
oh and he's like oh you've got it's like
oh
you oh this is a bad case of this and
this is you've got all these things yeah
and like i'm so sorry
and i kid you not the ekg starts doing
things
that it wasn't doing before
when he starts telling me this stuff and
i really i was like oh this is doing it
that's doing it that story is doing it
the story that you're sick yes that i'm
sick and all that that triggers inside
of me and all that that you know all the
the feelings that come around that so i
just was like i was like hold on hold on
hold on stop it for a second i'm like
telling the guy to just basically shut
up for a second and i was like i need to
get myself back because then he's like
he's like this and he's like yeah see
yeah
yeah you know and i was like no no no so
i i stopped and i worked through the
stuff
and i the ekg started to change back it
sounds so woohooy
i'll tell you i know it does doesn't it
it does it
and i was the last person in the world
to be woo-woo about things
so the guy's like what are you doing are
you like because the thing starts doing
different stuff i was like i'm just i
just need to get myself back to where i
was and i put it back because you'd
already done all this training from your
mind i'd already done the work and i got
myself back i breathed and i remembered
the healing and i remembered all the
things and i think it's really important
which i'm sure we'll talk about this as
it goes on to talk about for someone who
has no idea what this is and they're
just learning right here that it's not
just like a conscious like
oh
i'm just gonna tell myself i'm better
and i'll be better it's like literally a
subconscious that you you can't just be
like
power of the mind affirmations you know
what i'm saying right like it's a good
idea yes it's such a good conversation
so important to know about that so keep
going
but it that i had learned subconscious
tools i had learned and i'd cleared a
bunch of stuff that was supporting my
illness
that was that's the thing when i say
cleared a bunch of stuff i changed a
bunch of memories right and and it's
kind of like
you could tell yourself all day long i'm
healthy i'm healthy i'm and the way that
i'm eating is healthy for me but if your
subconscious tells you nope this way of
eating is going to make deteriorate this
way is going to make you sick and it's
like in your subconscious like you're
not going to feel healthy you're not
going to be healthy with the way that
you're eating that your consciousness is
telling you is healthy exactly yeah so
like can't mention before our
subconscious mind runs 95
of our actions thoughts behaviors
reactions
so i needed to do the subconscious work
to be able to consciously realize what
was happening and then engage in the
subconscious work
to make sure i was back
accessing the resources to say no i am
healed i am strong like all of these
different things which i had done in the
work
so you need to share about the what the
cardiologist said okay so then i go
through this whole thing
and i am telling him like i'm well but i
had just done two hours worth of testing
and he and he's like
so i explained he's sitting there very
stoic and everything i explained this
whole thing that i did and how i am
healed and i did it in the power of my
mind
and by doing this subconscious stuff and
he was sitting there and then he's like
literally he looks around very
conspiratorially and then he's like i'm
a part of a secret society
no
i'm not even kidding you and he's like
where we really do harness the power of
our mind it's like some ancient chinese
thing that he's a part of and he's like
i know what you're talking about wow
that's amazing and he's so then he
starts looking at my stuff new and he's
like
you're so much of your stuff looks
better he's like but your body
your physical health is not there yet
because my body had just been doing this
for so long so though my mind was ready
my body needed to catch up he was
totally on board with that so he's like
so you need to start exercising now for
dysautonomia or pots oh you don't
exercise because it's something with
your when your blood pressure doesn't
your blood pressure gets too low because
of this heart thing i'm this is for
those of you out there who are doing pot
you're like you're not getting it
exactly right
but basically yeah that's what it is and
so you don't exercise because if you get
overheated or whatever you'll pass out
okay
so
he's like you need to start exercising
and you need to do this and he gets on
this plan of health for me to get my
body caught up with my mind
and it was amazing and then each doctor
did the same thing with me and so three
months after this
i'm off of all meds
i'm in the gym
with leg pressing like what some crazy
and not 450 pounds or something
stronger than i had been in so many
years but not just that i was
emotionally like opened up
so
free and joyful and felt strong and i
was connected to my kids
it what i was connecting with my husband
it was like scales came off my eyes
and i was a new person that's amazing
heather and i never thought i was going
to do this
i had another job i did this other stuff
but then
i had a friend
who was like
totally freaked out by how quickly i got
well and she's like do you think this
would work for me she'd been suffering
from from insomnia for five years but
like
heavy duty insomnia it affected her
whole family's life she didn't have
another baby because of it she was
losing her job her husband was going to
lose his job because she was like it had
gotten so intense
so i was like i don't know if it will
work for you like we can give it a try i
did one session with her with my limited
knowledge at the time
she never did insomnia again wow it
changed her life i mean and
also the same thing happened with my
sister my sister was doing insomnia she
did a session with you
two sessions maybe yeah two i think she
does not experience insomnia anymore no
and it was so much other like
layered stuff behind that the insomnia
was just the thing presenting to say hey
we need some attention in here and i
feel like insomnia is like so the mind
like the mind is like it's out of all
the things insomnia would be like one of
the top ones that are like in the mind
for sure for sure anyways it's what
about
kit well do you have more to your story
how was that for you guys as a
relationship
so
like she said she was like opening up
she was stronger physically but also
again that was a metaphor for her
emotional strength
and it was
it was amazing to see my wife go from
like carrying her to the bathroom at
times and you know taking care of two
kids and work and all this stuff to her
being
just life of the party i mean she was
like let's have people over let's do
this so it was incredible i was so
supportive
that's you you keep getting well you
know you keep dealing with your past and
your trauma because i came from a very
very different
uh family life uh i grew up where
i would have said
no trauma
um very you know my parents still
together still loving each other you
know my sister whatever like very i'll
say sheltered home
um
and everything was kind of going in one
sense my way the way that i wanted life
to go i was married i had kids like
these are all the things i wanted it was
great
and
so she started getting like really well
emotionally and i
started
tanking emotionally it was weird it was
like i was the one who was always come
on let's go let's you know you've got it
let's get everything's great
everything's look at the bright side
that was kind of me
and all of a sudden she's all of a
sudden happy and doing well physically
emotionally and i started to just go in
a spiral but i didn't really realize
that at the time it was just like i
guess i was in a funk or whatever that
was just like the most annoying thing in
my life i feel like you're in a funk
today no i'm not
um but yeah it was i something happened
something was triggering me and i didn't
know what
and she eventually felt like i'm i'm
well are you not
happy that i'm well what's going on no
i'm so excited for you
long story short uh i kind of had a lot
of good coping skills of things are good
things are fine things or whatever
and it took me
probably two years of a year and a half
um to being like no this is great your
thing keep getting well to realizing
i got issues i got stuff but i didn't
really know what that was or how deep it
went i just knew that there was stuff so
again i started going into okay let's
let's deal with this let me let me
imitate let me understand how the mind
works how it's connected to our body all
these things and the dive was very deep
for me because i thought just touch up a
few things and all of a sudden i opened
this entire
life that i she had the scales fall off
of her i had scales on but there were
different scales they were scales of
everything's perfect
and so when those came off that's why
things were so hard for me it's like oh
my goodness
my parents weren't perfect my life
wasn't great going you know and all
these different things and and so i went
through a process for sure um a very
different process than her it was
emotional but it our how did it affect
our relationship um
it was hard like really hard like you
think oh she's getting freer that's
awesome because i was so wound up and so
tight so closed off that when she got
freer it was a threat to me emotionally
um it was a threat on so many different
levels um so
i started doing the work started getting
into it really started training uh
myself in as many things as i could with
the mind body connection as she had and
uh things started opening up and that
was that was a big big thing but i i had
to realize there was a lot of emotional
trauma growing up and a lot of that was
just stuffed and so anger bad
um you know feeling disappointed bad you
know just these are just things i didn't
do anymore and if there was something
really sensitive
like our sexual relationship or anything
there it was like oh let's talk about
those everything's fine everything's
good and so there's so many things
pinned up
that we just didn't talk about or that i
didn't open up to because i couldn't
bear to see anything wrong with myself
but when i did finally open those things
up
that's when things in our relationship
started changing that's when things in
my life started changing
and so it's not just the physical some
people it affects physically but trauma
affects people emotionally and that's
where i was at relationally emotionally
in my job everything was just
until it wasn't until i was able to
actually deal with it
that's incredible because you're coming
from two completely opposite spectrums
and both of you saying everything's fine
yeah exactly
right which
it listen if you're gonna do certain
coping skills which we all do to some
degree that's a good one that's a good
one like everything's good everything's
fine
but the fact of the matter is then
you're not really in touch like it's
very difficult to inhabit your body
and feel all your feelings and be in
touch with other people and humanity
when everything's fine all the time
because it's not right it just isn't now
that doesn't mean that we've got to be
negative nancy or you know all of that
stuff whatever that means
but we
can feel it and we can have health
around it emotionally and physically but
so many of us are not taught that i mean
whose parents
were these like beacons of emotional
intelligence
and that's not saying anything negative
about anybody right who taught them
who taught their parents
we've we live in a society of kind of
pull yourself up by your bootstraps and
just move on
and or you or you're on that other side
where you're this like sensitive
fragile person it's like we've got these
two extremes
and we don't have to live in these
extreme places so then you want to be in
the middle ground is what you're saying
like somewhere in the middle or
just maybe not even
i mean maybe just in our bodies
and really in tune with what we're
really feeling yeah in tune with our
experience
with the world
you know so for instance
i take issue with um
and teach a lot around empathy being
emotional suicide
which is it's a big trigger trigger
warning so explain this
what do you mean by this okay so empathy
is like the big thing now um
what empathy really means is that you're
trying to feel people's feelings
and that that's how you connect is by
feeling people feel what they're going
through or at least understand what
they're going through right understand
is compassion okay
yes feel their feelings
be there with them is empathy okay with
someone feel for someone
so i understand our i feel like this
this push for empathy is a reaction of
us being really
discompassionate
is that a word whatever of ourselves and
other people so we kind of go to this
other place of like you really the only
way to connect with someone is to feel
what they're feeling
and i think that that
it sounds good
but when we really do it it gets it gets
heavy and this is where we have um have
you ever heard of tertiary trauma
no it's it's secondary trauma it's um we
see it in doctors caregivers oh yes
sometimes even mothers and stuff like
that it's that
you're
so carrying someone else's stuff trying
to feel their stuff and be there for
them
that you're actually becoming
traumatized by their trauma that's a
really good way to explain it career
that has the top suicide count is
psychologists
because they're you know unintentionally
possibly but taking on so much stuff
yeah well a lot a lot of caregivers and
we get caregiver burnout and everything
it's because this
they're being told be empathetic be
empathetic get into their stuff feel
their feelings because you don't want
this cold brick wall trying to help you
out
but you you really can't do that you
can't feel another person's feelings we
actually can't do that
you can filter through your own personal
stuff to try to imagine what it would
feel like to feel their feelings yeah
but you can't actually feel their
feelings
so i teach about something called
compassionate empathy which is just
using the two words of saying
like utilize be if you're as present as
you can be in your body having dealt
with your stuff you're really able to
open this space for someone
and hold them in this space of their
highest self
and even if they don't show up into that
space as their highest self you still
know that that's they're capable of that
and that if they're doing whatever it is
they're doing they must have a really
good reason for it
that's really beautiful and it allows us
to be like i'm you know i'm here with
you yeah they're not feeling your
feelings but they're for you but they're
for you
right it's that thing of of so often we
think we need to feel some feel
for somebody or with somebody and if uh
the example you like to use is if
someone's in a pit right someone falls
into a pit what are we gonna jump in the
pit with them so that we can really then
no one's able to get out right no be the
strong one
see that they're in a pit help them out
of the pit
if they want help if they want it right
which we'll get into right yes okay
before we ask that which i'm really
excited to get into that topic like
specifically but before we get into that
can you explain
a little more in depth to make it less
woohooy right like what is the
neuroscience behind it the biochemistry
of the brain that really makes this as
possible as your as your experience was
okay
that was huge for me because i came in
from an eft perspective
and though i you know i didn't believe
in energy then
i definitely believe in it now but not
maybe not in a woo-woo since like
it's science now we're made up of energy
matter okay so what does it say what is
the science then about it so if you want
to know anything about us and the energy
that we have and how that some people
call it spirit some people call it
energy or life whatever it is
dr joe dispenza
has all the research okay he's done the
work of that uh and he so the brains get
into his stuff
he so i was able to take from him and go
okay energy is actually quantifiable
and we if it can be measured it's real
and then they've shown so many amazing
effects of that so utilizing that then
of course i did eft
um but i also then started studying okay
here's the thing i started seeing that
eft wasn't working for some people
and even for myself and for other people
who were using it and doing it
practitioners it stopped it didn't stop
working but there were certain things it
wouldn't work with or things would come
back for certain people it wouldn't work
certain people they're like it just
doesn't work everyone's different
everyone's different but i was like
i wanted to know more why and the idea
of energy was one thing but i was like
there's got to be more to this
so that's when i took a step back and i
started diving into the neuroscience i
knew our brain was a component
and i so i was like let me get into the
neuroscience
and it's all there
and so to do it in a layman's term
because you we can get really
nitty-gritty and a lot of research about
this
but i'll i'll make it easy
by saying our we are remember we're a
whole being and we're cyclical in the
sense that um a thought let's say
you drop a hammer on your toe
okay yeah the way that that works is
your toe will send information up to
your brain
and it says hey this happened
it's not sending pain
pain is not uh
it's it's not like sending pain it's
sending messages oh that's so
interesting i know
i feel like that's not how we're most
commonly understanding nerves right yeah
it's not like we're most commonly taught
that like oh it goes to the brain the
pain tells you you're in pain the brain
it tells you it tells the brain that
you're it tells the brain that you're in
pain no the brain is what filters and
says this is pain
okay because for us pain gets it
attention
and and the toe needs attention
so the brain it sends the messages up
the brain goes okay well let's send down
pain
and pain because
an an inflammation right it sends
inflammation it sends blood down it
sends heat down because heat brings the
you know it comes from the blood and it
heals right it's meant to heal and also
it brings our conscious awareness down
there
so
people think that we have pain nerves
even doctors will talk about pain nerves
or nerve pain it isn't it and doctors
you know that this is true but we just
don't talk about this that we don't have
pain nerves okay we have nerves that
carry information
so we're cyclical in that the brain it
comes up the brain goes okay send pain
down it sends the pain messages down
the toe goes ow
i'm in pain i need help then we do
whatever the tosin's message is back up
to the brain to tell it how it's going
right and we get this feedback loop it's
a constant feedback loop
but this is how we do everything so this
is how when
when we're being built as little people
everything that happens to us gets
brought in through our subconscious mind
it all we're through all of our senses
everything we see hear taste touch feel
smell is coming in okay can i interject
for a little bit please so this is
actually making me think of kofax
because those first like maybe five six
owies that he has gotten he had no like
there was no crying there was no he
didn't even react it was so crazy we
were like this kid doesn't care at all
if he gets hurt like he would like
scrape all of his toes and be like super
bleed like bleeding while he was like
playing on the skateboard just walk
inside not even care okay but after the
five or six time when he sees how his
siblings react to like oh no kovacs is
bleeding oh no get him a band-aid oh no
everyone's like freaking out right now
when he sees blood he's like oh no and
he starts crying yes but he didn't he
didn't actually cry before but i mean
can you really say that for extreme like
you get shot in the stomach right like
you can't be like you can't you can't
say you don't get pain from something
like that actually a lot of people who
get shot in the pit the stomach don't
feel pain right away well yes right when
you see aren't like war movies like you
see how they get shot and they're like
in this crazy
fight or flight mode they don't even
realize until they can calm down and
then they actually look and then they
start to faint right after they look at
it yes but i mean how can you really say
that they're not gonna if you train your
brain properly you wouldn't experience
extreme pain from some an extreme
physical trauma well we're not trying to
take pain out of the equation completely
pain's good actually yes okay so talk
about that when pain is used as
communication it's good you want to know
because there's you know if you heard
about that um syndrome and i can't think
of what it's called right now where
people actually don't feel pain the pain
receptors in their body are blocked
right they don't feel pain it's
important they they most of them don't
live very long okay that makes sense yes
you need to have some communication the
problem is
we've gotten so dissociated from
ourselves
that pain
that we don't we're not trusting our
intuition we're not listening to
ourselves we haven't taken care of
ourselves we're oh i'll care for someone
oh and we put ourselves
away again and again or we deal with all
this trauma
like all this thing happens to us and
we've never done anything about it
then the body starts to go
you don't listen to me
you don't hear me you don't take care of
me right so i'm gonna scream a little
louder right and that's what my body was
doing i see it now now i see all that
stuff as loving messages from my body
that it kept hollering it was just
beautiful kept like trying to get my
attention now i see all of those
diseases that i did
are loving
so when people were like you're saying i
did this to myself
i i'm saying i did it to myself but for
such good reasons and now i see it
completely all as love now it sucked
and i didn't want it to keep happening
that way
so i needed to deal with what was
happening and what my body was trying to
tell me
and now over time i've built this trust
with my body that yeah if i slam my hand
in the door i get pain
because it needs to do that but actually
i can not keep the pain for a long time
and kent's got a great story about this
i also have my this big tattoo that i
did in one sitting with no pain
uh until the last hour when i was over
it i was like
so i lost my you know i was like i'm
done but i did the whole thing with no
pain
because i went i'm like this is my
choice
i'm doing this i'm doing this to myself
and i knew i didn't need pain about it
right and so i was able to do that
but if i was trying to block a message
of like i'm being injured
then that's incongruent with my body and
that would that's not necessarily not
that's not what i would want to do so
are you was there something you were
going to say a story though oh yeah i
mean i well i don't know how many years
ago this was at our patio house a few
years ago i was out so we were having
people over and so one of our our side
door back door um i was trying to tell
everyone hey come on inside we're going
to eat or whatever and so i opened the
door and kind of swing it open and i put
my hand here talking to them and then
heather's trying to talk to me and so
i'm like oh what's up and then a huge
gust of wind comes now our back door is
steel oh it's like a full
out you know exterior door and it just
goes wham right on my hand
and i'm just like oh
you know i mean still door in your hand
something's gonna happen so i
immediately
there's some people that they're like oh
my goodness are you okay um i
immediately go to the other side of the
house and i just start working on myself
for like 10 15 minutes what i remember
feeling seeing all the different things
that we do that's kind of hard to
explain but i was working on myself
um 10 minutes later or so i come back
inside and i'm like
i'm okay
no swelling no broken anything wow no
like whatever and it really should have
left
a massive i mean it should have broken
up it should have whatever right so i
did this work
and and then now i'm not stupid so i
also had there's like do you want an ice
pack i'm like well it actually feels
okay no no it was hurting like at the
beginning it wasn't like i just never
hurt no it was like
really bad and but i worked on it and
then it didn't hurt anymore and then i
put ice on it because that's what smart
to do
um and then the next day i was like oh
yeah i can i can see that there was like
a little like like it's tight the next
morning okay he wakes up and he's like
my hand hurts that's right
and i'm like
is it bad and he's like what do you mean
he forgot i forgot but he was like my
hand hurts a little bit but he's going
like this
and i'm like and he had forgotten that
that had happened and i was like you
bring the doorstep he's like oh yeah
he's got this massive line of bruising
across his knuckles
but he had forgotten even what had
happened so was just like i don't know
why my hand is hurting wow that's that's
an insane story i know so are you guys
saying that like it's all just the
trauma that you need to deal with or
what role does like a healthy lifestyle
like play into it play into that is it
all just dealing with trauma or is there
more more to it than that no i mean you
could have
you know you could
you could do one or the other it's not
one or the other right if you deal with
your trauma but you're still treating
your body like trash and eating junk and
whatever else like that's not gonna be
good either really right versus oh i'm
like doing all the right health things
but you're not dealing with stuff your
body's not going to integrate those
healthy things well either like it's
both it's basically both absolutely it's
holistic and it comes from it really has
to do mostly with our motivation
if you're eating well and changing your
lifestyle and all of this stuff because
you feel like a big fat pig
right like if that's your mindset and
your you hate your body and you're doing
all of these things you can change your
lifestyle and for a little while you
might start to feel better again but i
guarantee you if you're doing that to
feel better
then it's going to come out some other
way so it's our belief system it's how
we believe what we believe about
ourselves who we are
deeply subconsciously in our core so
what would be the opposite of that then
someone who's doing it with not that
subconscious what would be the other
other end of the spectrum such a great
question okay so i'll use a really
relevant example we have a client right
now here doing a private retreat
i didn't know this about her but she
came she's a lot she just read the book
she's lost 32 pounds without even trying
her her blood pressure went down she had
high blood pressure it went completely
down her bad cholesterol went completely
down so she's telling me all of this
stuff
and i know it's because she started
feeling good about herself she was
dealing with a lot of the core stuff and
about memories and how she felt as a
child
and in her mind she was like
i feel like going out and exercising
like i feel like feeding my body good
food i want to take care of you i want
to do it i have to or i should exactly
that's i'm on the same page as you guys
about that i'm so about the mind body
connection as well as the lifestyle
practices living in a way that's healthy
for your body inside and out and that if
you have that positive outlook on
yourself you will naturally want to do
those things right yes yes and that's
our like factory default setting is to
feel good about ourselves
and it's it's everything that we're born
into and given and what we see that
tells us otherwise and we have to deal
with that programming we have to we will
only output what was input and you can
positive affirm all day long we were
just talking with some of our course
students about this about the use of
positive affirmations yeah actually
let's get into that because i was going
to ask you
like what is the difference between what
you guys are doing with mind change and
compared to the all the other types of
things like laws of a lot of attraction
positive affirmations even you bringing
up eft and tapping like what makes what
are you doing that's different well i'll
start off by just saying mind change is
a conglomeration of a lot of different
modalities and things that we studied
out
and one of the things that heather was
honing in on is why does this work for
what does emdr work for this person and
not for this person why does eft work
for this issue and not that issue like
all these different things and so what
we try to do is figure out the why like
why it works and it's all having to do
with the way that that person represents
or the representational systems that
they use to input memory and so certain
things so what we've tried to do with
mind change is take all the things that
work
and and we're going to work with a
client and it's not going to be the same
every time it's not like one program of
this thing she was saying earlier or
just do this or whatever it's it's going
to be different depending on the person
and so we're going to take that person
where they're at how they input things
and then reconstruct deconstruct and
create new neural pathways for them so i
just wanted to start off by saying it's
it's not just this random thing that we
made up we we pulled from as many good
things as we could
um changing whatever you know we didn't
add our own flair to things and and then
so i'll let you share about the positive
affirmation stuff
well yeah i mean and that's such a good
point i was going to mention that we we
looked into of course eft emdr dnrs
uh nlp i don't know any of these
impressions
because they all had like you'd hear
these amazing stories of these healing
stories from these people and then you'd
hear someone but i tried it didn't work
and i was like oh there's gotta be
something so i started researching how
we create memories and how that gets
stored in our subconscious mind
and we have all these like things of
well positive thought therapy and say
your affirmations and even you know so
many different things out there and
you'll you'll always have the person
that's like it didn't work for me
so with this stuff it takes how we work
neurobiologically across the board like
all humans are going to have that
feedback loop
right all of us do it all humans
utilize memory and memory the way that
we reconsolidate memories or put them in
and put them in is done the same
and all the way that they're represented
is through one system all of that is for
every human being right so we
look when you step back at it and look
you're like
oh
right oh this is why all of this stuff
works when it works and why it doesn't
when it doesn't and so we put something
together that works for anybody for
anything
all the time wow so i'll use positive
thought therapy as an example
i just want to say thank you to all the
people that have gone before us because
right yeah i don't think any of these
someone asks oh is this not good because
i've been doing this and i was like no
everything is good
you just got to figure out what works
for you yes so all those modalities are
great right uh they're incredible we
just kind of took the best of the best
and even like i mentioned before our
reductionist way of educating health
professionals
is great for those of us who aren't
have to stay aligned with one way of
thinking we can step back and go that's
brilliant that's brilliant put it all
together and it's that's that's really
what mind change is that's really
beautiful so let's take a positive
affirmation let's say that you might
realize something in your life is maybe
you feel like you're not good enough and
it keeps reoccurring in different ways
you're like you know what i'm going to
start affirming i'm going to start
law of attraction like speaking it out
i'm going to call it into existence this
i am worthy i am worthy i am worthy and
you can put your little stickers up and
you can write your little things down
so if in your subconscious mind
every time you say i am worthy your mind
hears it
right and it brings up all of the proof
of whether that's true or not
if in your subconscious mind you hold a
load of proof
that you're not worthy
then every time you say i am worthy your
brain's gonna go um no you're not and
here's all the reasons why right exactly
and it reinforces those neural pathways
right it makes them stronger fires them
up every single time so the the example
i like to give is
if uh if someone has a pet
and they have a dog and the dog poops in
the middle of the kitchen what do you do
clean it up clean it up right that's
what you do now you could
put a mat over it right just like hey
we're just going to make sure this was a
you could spray it you could potpourri
you could febreze it you could do all
these things
you could make it look pretty you could
even put like a little table with
flowers and all this stuff but if you
don't clean it up what's still
underneath of it the poop right so you
can positive affirm your life as much as
you want but you actually have to get
rid of the poop in your life the
negative thoughts the negative the
trauma the stuff that we've been holding
on to you have to let go of that in
order for
there to be beautiful flowers that
actually matter in order for there to be
you know you can put them out there you
can do whatever you want but you've got
to be able to take the old out before
putting the new in
right because you can think positive
affirmation
an affirmation is anything you affirm
so if we're trying to affirm these
positive things because actually we
don't feel them
then then we're not what we're affirming
is the thing that we feel actually what
we have proof for
that's when positive affirmations don't
work
right
now clean the house clean the
clean it up
rewire
change the neural pathways now you can
be like i am worthy and your brain goes
yeah yeah here's the proof yes you are
yes yes you are and here's all the
reasons why and it reinforces those
neural pathways so i have a question
it might be really frustrating for
someone who has experienced maybe mental
illness their whole life
or a physical ailment their whole life
to be told that like you just have to
change your mind yeah so what is your
thoughts what are your thoughts for the
topics of like toxic positivity
victim shaming not being inclusive to
those who just who are going through
something like how do you respond to
that
so
what i what we want to stay say with
mind change is this not everybody's
gonna jive with this message right
um it isn't forever it wouldn't have
been for me i'll tell you right now had
you said i wouldn't have heard
these things
the way i know them now
i would have heard it in a va my filters
were too thick i could it was
keeping those illnesses were keeping me
safe like if you were told earlier if
you weren't in the place that you just
so happened to be that right spot in
your mind where you were ready to try
maybe anything yes i was gonna die that
was my other option right so i really
got to that sort of rock bottom you
don't have to hit rock bottom but you do
have to be at that place where it's like
i'm going to challenge
what i think i know i'm going to
challenge my my filters right or at
least i'm going to consider that i might
have filters
yes so if that would have been so
triggering for me to hear
like like i said when it said you're
doing this to yourself that my illnesses
were stuff that i was doing versus
having rather than things that i had oh
that would have been a trigger fiesta
for me
before but i was in a place where i was
like could that be
and it changed everything and your mind
was in the right place to hear it yes
because most people i don't know if this
is like most or not but like you really
don't want to be like oh you're doing
mental illness you know like that's
a lot a lot of people wouldn't receive
that well no part of the what the reason
they're doing mental illness is because
it's a protection mechanism anyway
for good reason
for good i can't yeah
remember that everyone's doing an
illness or an emotional issue or a
mental issue whatever for really really
good reason and so with mind change we
we come from a place of again you're
doing this for a good reason and we're
going to give you that space like
there's no there's no judgment there's
no
and when you're ready your mind will
will get there kind of like heather i
mean she was on this journey of being
ill why didn't she get out or why didn't
she get better
two years earlier right she wasn't in a
place to hear it even though there were
people telling her have you thought
about it she wasn't there for my
relationship with heather i mean it took
kind of us getting to like a
place in our relationship before i
decided okay maybe there's something
that i'd be willing to look at yourself
right and so and that's okay everyone's
where they're at and i don't think that
it's wasting time to well i'm not ready
for this that's okay when you are you
are yeah everyone's on their own journey
and like so specifically then about
trauma what is trauma because like
you're saying it's not just those who
have experienced sexual abuse or
extremely hard childhoods or
circumstances but it can also be someone
who was raised in you know a regular
regular childhood with sweet loving
parents and
so what what is trauma exactly then so
trauma well do you want to share her go
for it trauma
trauma is trauma
for one person trauma can be
rape that's a trauma
for another person it can be
um you know a third grade a teacher
giving you a dirty look or something
like that yeah i'm not i'm not judging
which one's worse there's no they're
both
bad for the person at the time and
they're both not good in general right
like we don't but
but trauma is trauma and so it's not
that well this doesn't really matter
let's deal with this no let's deal with
both let's deal with everything right i
don't think you're necessarily trying to
be like oh you know teacher giving you a
bad look is just as bad as someone being
right you're not saying that just to be
clear i think i know you well enough i
know you all know that's not what you're
saying i think it's more so that like
let's deal with both yeah right you
gotta deal with whatever is there
there's no
it doesn't matter about level of
judgment it's just hey there's trauma
here so in our relationship you know i
mean for her trauma was
uh being beaten or sexually abused when
she was a kid like that was her trauma
for me i remember even when we got
married like her raising her voice a
little bit was trauma to me stop yelling
at me i was like uh yeah i was a baby so
um but that's because i don't like being
yelled at either though no right but
what we perceive is someone yelling at
us right she was just raising her voice
versus like get out of it you know for
me it was trauma and so what am i just
like weaker because i have less you know
no it has to do with how i take it in
and trauma's trauma is trauma so we need
to deal with both that's the point and i
love um dr gabor mate he's big in the
trauma field right now and he he says
trauma is anything that causes a
response in our autonomic nervous system
anything that our body feels like it
needs to
respond to
can be trauma
so and that's what people don't fully
understand is trauma
there whatever when something happens to
us depending on the way that we see the
world our view of the world
when something happens to us our body
will respond to it
and how our body responds to it can be a
traumatic response
if it
puts all the lights on i kind of
i was thinking about an example a
metaphor of kind of like a smart house
like you move into this beautiful house
and it's a smart house
and it can you know it learns with you
and it's got um
mechanisms to keep you safe
right and so you're think you're safe
your everything's good but something
happens and let's say you get broken
into
and and maybe tied up and robbed i mean
that it
everything wow now is like
you're on high alert so you get your
systems buffed up
which you should right in your mind you
should you're thinking oh my gosh i
didn't have enough stuff happening well
the problem is
now you've got a smart house
so you're it's like what is danger all
it's looking for now is danger
so now danger becomes anything that
moves out in the night
yeah and any like when the lights turn
on and then the person inside like
with everything right for when things
become so dangerous for so long and
you're on and their house is like danger
danger danger
eventually we get desensitized
to the danger
or people come over let's say you've
invited people over and you forget that
your smart house you didn't tell your
smart house that people were coming over
people come up and it starts alert you
know danger alert alert alert and
because
you're programmed to when it goes off
that's the only thing keeping me safe
you go you get into this complete and
heightened state yeah so you're hiding
in the closet you're hiding in your safe
room and your people who you invited
over are out there like
um hello yeah okay this now starts to
affect your relationships
because now these people are like what
is going on didn't she invite me over is
this okay what's happening why is this
all happening right right then you
finally come to the door you're all like
and they're like are you okay and you're
like yeah i don't know items i'm freaked
out you freaking i forgot in this house
and everything yeah so now your friend
and you're like
yeah
right
and then okay now everything's okay
so you see where i'm going with this
over time it affects other people too
you're just on high alert so oftentimes
these people who've been struggling and
they're doing mental illness and
everything like this or physical illness
they don't their body is in this
response
and people are have to respond to their
responses
and they're doing the best they can yeah
but it starts to affect everything
it affects their relationships it
affects their work and it becomes this
identity
which it would be hard not to right
because it's affecting everything even
small things within my own childhood i
have like attached to part of my
identity and i realize that sometimes
like oh okay why is why do i hold on to
this so much
you know yes well we were just talking
about you know the holidays are coming
up and so many people have a lot of
trauma wrapped up into the holidays and
we were talking with some of our core
students about this in a mentoring call
about preparing yourself for the
holidays and explaining the neurobiology
behind why holidays tend to be so
triggering for people
it's because all of our senses are
heightened we're smelling unique things
and seeing unique things and it's
triggering everyone and usually to the
good
right so many people love the holidays
it's like you can't help yourself you
hear the music and you see the glitter
and you're like oh you smell the food
and the cinnamon and you get these giddy
feelings
those feelings are simply a result of
your brain pulling up these memories and
attaching it to positive positive things
right so can we go into a little bit
about my personal experience then with
you with with mind change um i know i've
talked about it on my youtube channel
before so people can go and watch that
video i'll put the link in the show
notes for people to watch that so we
don't need to get like 100 into it but
what you just said there was so
important because that was when you
would you guys decided to help me with
this well let me explain it i was
pregnant with my third and i really
wanted a shorter labor this time i had
two home births already wonderful
homeburst i loved the experience but
they were very very painful and very
very long
and i had told you because you were
talking about this mind change thing and
i was like would it work with like labor
like can i make my labor go quicker can
i make my labor be like less painful and
you're like yes 100
i'm like what like i've never done it
before by the way i was like it's gonna
work right yeah yeah so you've never
done it specifically for labor never and
now you've done so many no holy moly so
many okay so many yeah after we like
talked about it and you're like 100
ellen you can and i was so excited about
that idea because i really wanted a
shorter labor my first two labors were
like 24 and 26 hours long and i would
have loved to be one of those stories
where i was like yeah labor felt good
you know
you hear those stories they're a rarity
but you're like that's not me i can't do
that and so when you i was really open
to that but i still was skeptical and
you're like yeah just come over me and
ken will do this session on you for like
i think it was like a two-hour thing it
was actually only like four days before
i went to labor like we pushed it
towards the end we're like let's just do
it right at the end
we we go into i'm like going into it
totally skeptical but open like okay and
you're like good thing is though ellen
that even if you don't believe that
it'll work it's still gonna work i was
like what
is it all about them i was like all
right so we do this we do the thing and
it was so funny because whatever highly
remember the things you were saying we
should people should go watch the
youtube video of like when we give the
detailed message but i started to feel
contractions
when you were telling me to feel those
contractions like and of course i was
close to labor so it makes sense
especially um but i was like that's
weird like i literally was feeling what
contractions feel like and you had asked
me what do you want your labor to be i
was like i would love for my labor to be
eight hours long
and to like feel like it felt good to
feel like it felt
just empowering and just not painful and
you're like okay change the word from
not painful to like something else like
what do you want it to feel like you had
me label exactly the sensations i wanted
it to feel like
and i'll be darned my labor was eight
hours long
and exactly
to the t of what i was envisioning and
hoping for i couldn't even believe it i
was on such a high from scout's birth it
was like even though the first one is
like the most like incredible like just
awe-strucking like you pull a gooey baby
out of your vagina and you're like
but scout's birth was like just so
transformative for me because i was in
control and you had told me
like you're like you have this identity
that labor is supposed to be hard and we
we kind of pulled back from like what
was my
version growing up of what labor was
supposed to be and it all came down to
my first memory of what labor was
supposed to look like was my aunt jane
love you aunt jane she's probably
listening
say telling telling um me about my mom's
labor and how she was there and it was
so long and it was over 40 hours and she
just couldn't get you out so she had to
have a c-section it was so painful and
so long so like in my head labor was
long labor was painful
and so that's it was almost like this
prideful thing i attached to it like i
did it it was so hard but i did it and
the thing is like that's all fine and
great if you want to do that but when i
was like i don't want to do that this
time right i want it to feel good and to
be shorter because i thought the second
one would surely be shorter everyone
tells me a second one's shorter it goes
so much faster and when it didn't go
faster i was so mad i'm like what am i
doing wrong why is it just as long and
it was like this thing that i was like
labor's long that's just what it's
supposed to be so when you did this like
literally just a few days later i
literally got the birth of my dreams i
remember smiling through the
contractions there was a moment of
weakness where i don't know if weakness
is the word but i still yeah you're like
no don't use that word
because it wasn't weakness right it was
just doubt it was doubt it was doubt
yeah and it was good reasons for doing
it yeah because you were just you got
into that space where it's about to
happen yeah
but then you um yeah and i called you
over because heather's like i'm right
here on call if you want me to come over
you know because andrew's like yeah for
sure i'll get heather over here when you
wanted because i started to be like
at first i'm like yes i'm doing this
it's gonna go quick and it's feeling
good but then it started to not feel
good and i was like oh no i can't do it
i'm not doing it right it's not it's
painful and then it felt even worse and
it felt way worse so then heather comes
over here in the middle of the night i'm
out in like our yard in the middle of
the night wearing a robe and you just i
don't remember what you said but you
like you said something to me and it got
me back on track and i started to be
like yes i can do this i am doing this
i'm doing it how i want it and i was so
in control to the point that i'm not
even kidding i told my body when to give
late like when to give birth exactly
when and where like it was crazy i
couldn't believe it and i realized i
i was like
going through the motions and i wasn't
giving birth even though it was getting
close to the eight hours and then i
realized oh i hadn't told my birth team
to come yet because i was so like in my
head oh they don't need to come it's
gonna be a while because that's what my
first two were like and then i was like
wait no they have to come for me to feel
comfortable to give birth like
my story my vision my plan was like
they're gonna be there and and
i don't know it's hard because it's like
you really are you in control are you
not i get both sides completely but in
this particular experience i was so as
soon as they got there i was like i'm
gonna have one more contraction outside
i'm gonna look at the moon and then i'm
gonna come inside get in the tub and
then i'm gonna push and give birth and
that's exactly what i did i couldn't
even believe it it was just as soon as
like my dad got there she was there for
the sandy's birth too
and you know the first time when she
came where sandy's where she's like oh
you got a ways to go and i was like what
she was like how much longer she's like
you're one contraction closer to giving
birth i'm like ew
don't tell me that
but then when she came with scouts she's
like oh you're moving right along
you're about there and i was like i am
like even though i knew that i was it
was just crazy anyways it was so
euphoric i couldn't believe it i was on
such a high not only the fact that i had
just given birth but the fact that i did
it how i wanted it and i was in complete
control it was just an insane experience
so that that was incredible to do that
with you guys i couldn't believe it how
you guys are just so so special so
special do you have maybe like wrapping
it up do you want to tell maybe one or
two other testimonials that you've had
personally with helping other people
yeah um well since we're on the story of
births yeah and things i'll share a
client's story so i worked with this
uh with this woman who
you know she's great she had some health
stuff that she wanted to get over
uh some beliefs some different things so
we worked this is about a year ago or
nine months ago or something we worked
together
um and it was great she i think she had
done some insomnia some other things
i did two sessions with her and she was
just where she wanted to be she felt
healthy she felt good and i you know
followed up with her a little bit later
like how you doing her health was great
everything was good she was sleeping
great like everything was just great one
of the things that she wanted to work on
specifically was she didn't believe that
she could get pregnant because of her
health
that belief just like aunt jane is that
her name yeah uh that belief came from
doctors saying well you know this is
your health and this is where you're at
so i'm not sure that you know having
babies is in your you know in your alley
kind of a thing and so she started to
believe that so we worked through all of
that stuff and kind of
you know push forward to what is the
future going to be and she could see
having a baby it was great
i didn't hear from her um after you know
a little bit and hear from her for about
i don't know six months nine months i
ended up working with her mom and all
these different things
um
she got a hold of me a handful of months
ago
and she said
hey
guess what i'm pregnant and i was like
oh that's awesome and so you know in a
short time she got pregnant um she
wanted to do a session just about like
how she was feeling she was feeling kind
of anxious about the pregnancy and
things like that great we did a session
everything's good everything she feels
great about it she knows it's gonna go
smooth
so i say great you know fill me in when
the time's there
a couple of weeks later now she was
gonna give me a testimony and a couple
of weeks later i was like hey can you
you know let me know what's going on and
she said
i'm not sure i can i just found out that
i actually had a miscarriage and i was
like oh i'm so sorry
um and i basically wrote her and i said
hey listen i'm happy just because i
loved working with you i'm happy to help
you through that grief let's do a
session i'm just going to give it to you
pro bono let's i'll just give it to you
let's do a session together oh that'd be
great
so
a week and a half goes by
um
she gets back to me and she's like hey
um don't know if you still want to give
me a free session but i actually had
worked through some things i went to a
doctor and realized i didn't have a
miscarriage so there was a few weeks
where she it was about i think it was 18
days where she was told you're having a
miscarriage to 18 days later oh my
goodness you have a healthy child
growing inside of you
no i know so much of this do they
sometimes get miscarriages wrong i want
to know i know i've never heard of that
i mean she was bleeding but i'm sure
yeah so
regardless there was she had done all of
this work and i will tell you i i
i have a deep deep belief
that the work that she did letting go of
you know grief from before letting go of
oh no am i gonna get pregnant and then
even fast forwarding to what this
pregnancy is gonna be what this birth is
going to be like what it's gonna be like
to hold my child all these everything
that she had rewired i'm telling you i
really believe that she saved that baby
from her own power from within so i did
this session with her a couple weeks ago
um and just really letting go of any
other fears that are and she is just
pumped she's like and this baby is
healthy and it is
medically uh and she's just so excited
about the birth we walk through that
walk through a lot of different things
so it's really cool to go from i can't
have babies
to oh my goodness i can and i'm pregnant
to oh what's going to happen i might
lose this baby i did lose this baby too
no i worked through it and i saved this
baby wow that is really really that's an
incredible story i know
we have so many it's hard to we try to
we very much protect client
confidentiality we don't use the names
or anything we don't actually do a ton
of testimonials just because so much of
what people come to us with is very deep
and personal yeah but i i mean there are
countless stories of people
healing
massive traumas
incest rape like things that they were
in therapy with for so many years that
they've been able to overcome
chronic illnesses um i mean so many
things relationship marriage stuff i
mean eczema i mean we get a lot there's
a lot of eczema happening right now
and a lot of doctors will tell you
eczema is like you can't heal eczema
like you can treat it oh my gosh of
course you can heal eczema right and
then what the reason is behind it use
this cream or that cream or whatever and
so we've had a lot of people who come in
and then don't you know don't do the
eczema anymore
a lot of mental health stuff
that and the mental health one is really
tricky for people to get to the place
where they feel like they can address it
like it's something
that maybe they are doing but for very
good reason and so
really incredible stuff with the mental
health
i was diagnosed bipolar manic depressive
was on medication so much when i from 16
years old and really felt like i had a
lot of identity around those was told
i'd be on medication for the rest of my
life
and those are not and again for people
who
choose that route there's
no judgment we really can't judge
anything no because
i know that if someone's doing something
it has something we'll say or whatever
it's for a very very good reason
they the body doesn't just willy-nilly
do this kind of stuff for no reason
absolutely people have great reason and
oftentimes it's keeping them safe
we might not understand it consciously
but i've been in enough so many sessions
around the world to know that people
there is something
that their mind is telling them it's
safer to do this than something else
right i think the hardest part the most
sensitive part around this discussion is
this not something you're actually
saying but that can easily be construed
that it's your fault or you're choosing
to do this and
just the the the language behind it
which is difficult to navigate with but
also without um just making it seem like
it's someone's fault when it's not i
know yeah no it's so triggery yeah and i
and i know that there's going to be
people that instantly get that and feel
that they may have stopped listening the
minute they heard that even if we're not
saying it which i totally understand and
i was there once too
but what we are never saying is that
it's someone's fault right exactly never
that's why i brought that up because i'm
like it could be easy for someone to say
this is what they said it's my fault
right even though you never said that no
but by just you know the nature of the
conversation that's an easy thing we can
we can just respond as saying that like
oh they must be saying that it's my
fault that i'm doing this or that i am
experiencing this and that's not what
you're saying no but it it that's
if that's if that's you out there
feeling that
what i will tell you is
that is there's a core belief at play
this fault blame guilt shame thing it's
it's usually learned in childhood it's
usually used as a coping mechanism to to
change to do better
if i can guilt myself enough i'll do
better or if someone shames me enough i
won't do it or you know something like
that and the body's like no
so this i'm doing something i can't help
you you should you know this is not my
fault
so strongly the body's
trying to speak that and i would say i
would i agree with you it is not your
fault right no the body is for you
absolutely 100 for you so when there's
physical ailments when there's emotional
mental ailments that are going on
it's actually your body doing exactly
what it's supposed to do
if you're constantly thinking about sad
depressive things then your body's gonna
produce those chemicals if your body if
you're constantly thinking about a
trauma or an issue or whatever then yeah
there's going to be even if it's
subconscious right and if you haven't
dealt with it then it is constantly
subconscious so your body's doing what
it needs to do right but what if what if
we could focus what if those neural
pathways in our brain could light up the
ones that we want to be there or create
new ones to a life that we do want how
would that affect our mental health our
physical health right and so it's what
we focus on it's so what we focus on my
dad actually has like a mental health
story he was diagnosed with bipolar
manic depressive um basically my whole
childhood he had a lot of medications he
was taking one medication for it or a
couple and he was taken something for
that something gave him vertigo and then
he took something for the vertigo and so
he was on medications for my whole
childhood i remember like growing up
witnessing experiences through his like
what he was experiencing um but he has
actually with the help of his doctors
which obviously is always recommended
got off all of his medications he hasn't
done a specific mind change but he
actually wants to do because he still
wants to work on himself even more just
like we all have work we can do but i'm
amazed by when he shifted
shifted the power to himself something
clicked within him and he took control
of his health through his lifestyle he
went plant-based he started um not only
just plant-based but like in all of her
lifestyle facets right it wasn't it
wasn't just about like like um that it
wasn't in control anymore he was in
control now and he he got off of all of
his medications in the last couple years
i couldn't even believe it my whole
childhood from that to this like he's a
total he's he seems like a totally
different person it's it's amazing i'm
so like just thankful for his like
redeeming story and there's so many like
that and it's really helpful i think to
hear those stories
um but
let's just talk really quickly about
your course can you tell everybody a
little bit about this course that you
just came out with yes so that anybody
who is looking like okay i'm ready i am
pumped for this oh sorry for the noises
guys it's actually dark now if you're
not watching this there's like hokey
frogs and birds and i don't know what
that car was but recycles
so can you tell everybody about this
course that you came out for people who
are looking who are ready to like heal
and grow and they want a tool to be able
to access yeah so obviously there's my
wife's book right mind change yeah
that's that's a deep dive and that
that's like hey i'm gonna learn what i
need to learn and then start to work on
myself but some people really want to go
even deeper and so that's what we do in
the course is we go into the
neurobiology the neurochemistry of okay
how does a thought become what we do and
all these other things so it goes even
deeper but then it's it's a really a
large portion of it is teaching you how
to change your own mind how to use the
techniques the tools the things that we
do
how do you work on yourself and so
that's the biggest things we want people
to i mean we're only two people we work
with a lot of clients but we want people
to know that the power doesn't come from
us the power the power comes from
themselves from within from our own
brain
and so we want people to be able to work
on themselves to heal themselves because
we all are capable of that and i'll even
add to that it's
mind change is not just for those we've
talked a lot about trauma right mind
change is not just for oh i have a lot
of trauma or i have a lot of issues
right now it can be hey i just want to
level up like i just want to i i feel
like i'm in a really good place
are there any hurdles or are there any
places that i want to get to that i'm
not sure how to get to great those are
just blocks subconscious blocks that you
can actually get rid of and then level
up in your life so that's what this
course is is yeah working on yourself
from whether it's physical stuff whether
it's emotional stuff or just hey i want
to get better and better and better as a
human being and be the best me
i can be right but it's cool because
there's a student community you get to
be a part of there's you know facebook
groups private groups community groups a
lot of different things you can share a
little bit more and mentoring we do
private mentoring for the music
because
the one-on-one sessions are great and we
love that but it's we feel like it's
limiting right i get booked out months
and months in advance right there's only
so many people you could reach that way
yes so that was the book was like let's
just get it out there so that's
accessible to anybody
and then we realized people want more so
we're like okay so we did the course and
the course really gets deep into all of
that stuff and i highly recommend the
course for anyone who is interested in
this stuff it's it's intense work it is
okay sorry keep going
but i highly recommend it but it's not
like hard work it's like deep work it's
deep work yeah but we i feel like we
make it pretty user friendly pretty easy
that's awesome to do it's not like
and then you have to do this one thing
for an hour every day and it involves
you twisting into this shape and you
know it's not that right it's pretty
user friendly and then the other thing
that we've done is so we've got the
course it's out there we really want to
support people we want to train more
people to do this we actually have a few
associate practitioners who've been
trained who also can offer sessions
we've been walking with who've done
multiple courses with us yeah and they
help in the community so it's really
cool
and then um we started a non-profit
and it's called the mind change movement
because ideally we want to make this
stuff accessible affordable
to anyone who needs it like it shouldn't
be
you know those with big bank accounts
that get the help that they need right
but we need like there's a lot of people
out there who have the money and you
know need to give it to someone for a
non-profit sort of situation
this is what we're doing so it's kind of
brand new but what we would like to do
is we want to do more research we want
to get the research out there to show
you what's happening in your brain when
you do this work to show you why it
works right because it's just the
beginning stages really it's so really
still in the beginning stages i mean we
i've used it for eight years now i think
or more i've worked with hundreds and
hundreds of clients thousands at this
point probably now and then ken we you
know got ken trained up and he works
with a lot of people but the more we
work the more people that we bring in
the more we grow the more we learn and
then does it all isn't it also providing
um services for people who can't afford
it right we have scholarship programs
yes um and it's really cool because
we've already
gotten a few donate or a couple
donations and they're like hey i just
want this to go to somebody who needs it
yeah that's beautiful and i want them to
be able to heal people that can't maybe
afford but they still want the healing
and need the healing so that's really
neat and we have people that fly in for
private retreats but we also are going
to be doing these big group retreats
which i cannot even they're going to be
so
like mind-blowing yeah it's gonna be
people's lives completely change
and even a client that we have just that
we're doing a
retreat with now she's like i thought it
would take longer it's like i've had one
session i feel like everything i wanted
has already happened wow she's got some
amazing three more days
so that happens so often people are like
i didn't expect like i had high
expectations but i didn't know i would
change this much
so amazing yeah i mean so many great
things the course though probably is
where we can get the most people yes
definitely check out the course for
those of you listening or watching i'll
put the link in the show notes so i have
one more question for you what are three
what are three things that people who
are listening or watching today can take
away from this
this episode what can they do i mean one
thing i'll say is
you can create i mean you know you can
destroy the things that are going on in
your mind in your life the trauma but
you can create whatever life that you
want you really can i know that sounds
like some kind of
you know thing you'd hear at some big
weekend retreat kind of thing you go
home and forget all about it but like
you have the power already within you
if you'll just harness it so what do
they do what what what can they do in
the meantime
i'd say really read the book because the
book lays it all out there
and if you want to kick back on it
that's okay kick back on it but the
research is there
so i make the book really user-friendly
but the research is there you want to
dig deeper it's all there in the
recommended reading yeah if you want to
go deeper go to the course if you want
to go even deeper do sessions like
there's ways to do it but it it's we
want people to be empowered in
themselves that's amazing yes listen
there's nobody's stuck nobody has to be
stuck
even if it's been happening for 50 60
years even if it's been generationally
passed down even if they've told you
it's in your dna
you know
anything can be changed
and we can think differently about it
and feel differently about it and that
we're worth it well we are so worth it
being being able to enjoy our lives
that's beautiful so that's what that's
what i want people to know that's
amazing thank you guys so much for
coming on here this was all like super
impactful information i know it's
changed my life for sure
and it's helped so many people so i
really appreciate you guys coming out
and explaining all this i hope that
everybody listening can gain something
really really important about
about this topic thank you so much
[Music]
you